and also we had a change in the twins
lineup right ref snyder who ran into the
wall on that home run yesterday by ryan
mob castle originally in the lineup and
then scratched yeah they uh they did
they did what ken griffey jr did
early on and
[Music]
but right here he just doesn't he runs
out of territory and
and it hits the right shoulder
and then they kind of did what ken
griffey jr did this with one of the
young outfielders i think brian husky
did it yeah
and down he goes so
good way to get started for bruce
zimmerman records a strikeout one down
check it bring them up that's what
fielding culprit says down at first base
two down
popped up
let's see if we got a play here mount
castle should yes he does
and the twins down couple of strikeouts
for zimmerman in the first orioles come
to bat no score
and uh as the notes refer to him big
mike six seven 280 pounds
i wonder why they call him that chad
but he can pitch a little bit yeah
one strike to mullins
right field and deep
ostidio on the run and it's off the wall
mullins around second
into third they'll hold him up there
with a triple
there's an rbi opportunity for tree
mancini the lead off triple from cedric
mullins just got a piece of that one and
that got a piece of garber who's down
edger rocco baldelli checking on his
catcher
oh wow yep
well you wear a protective cup
but
mitch garver's
knight is done there's rook belt
he's got a strap on the gear we'll be
delayed a little while longer
and the only one available to play right
now
is nick gordon and he hasn't played in
over a week
getting loose out there and it's for his
benefit and also for
york vet who
hey when you're the only catcher left on
the bench you've got to be ready at a
moment's notice but i don't know that
anybody thought it would be this quick
center field
rbi base hit tree mancini and the
orioles have a one nothing lead it's a
nice way to start juno
and the 2-2 pitch a fly ball left field
and deep back it goes deep it goes and
gone
right on cue garlic
delivers again off of lefty his fourth
home run this season
and the twins answer back it's a 1-1
game in the third
sharply hit and that'll leak through
on the ground a roller through the
interior and target donaldson to forward
for the two out single and that'll bring
crews to the plate
and this one's hit hard to right center
field mullins is back still going back
and he will make a catch that is
unbelievable
sliding into the right center field wall
one of the best catches you will ever
see
cedric mullins
has just brought the house down
on a backhand and on a slide colliding
with the right center field wall he did
the impossible
and he gets a standing o heading back to
the orioles dugout with his teammates
there to greet him
an amazing grab by mullins
2-2 pitch
and cedric mullins is doing it all a
triple a single
maybe the best catch of the year
there goes mullins
throw down to second
not in time stolen base number nine
stealing faces triple singles catches
having himself a night here in the third
inning well that's what he brings to the
table meanwhile back at the play the
ball and two strikes to mancini that's
roped into left field
mullins has the green light he's around
third he will score mancini for the
second time in this game has driven in
cedric mullins
pineda
the six foot eight right hander
delivers to santander and this one's a
line drive base hit right field mancini
advances to second
and the orioles has something going
again here in the third
so here's galvez switch hitter hitting
left-handed against pineda mancini at
second santondar at first and there's
one out and this one's lined into right
field that's going to get down for a
base hit mancini turns third he will
score three straight hits
and the orioles have grabbed a three to
one lead
but ain't already full cop pitch galvez
running
bounce to the right side the only plays
at first and the orioles get another run
they started freddie galvez wise move
one-two pitch
that's hit well
deep left center field way back
and it short hops the wall for a double
that'll get galves in
mount castle with an rbi double
fourth run of the inning and the orioles
lead at 5-1
and pedro hits this one to left field
it's way back pedro severino goodbye
pedro severino
at long last
his first home run since the 8th of
april
that was opening day in baltimore and
it's a six one baltimore lead
two and two to cruz leading off the twin
six
yeah
and cruz
first and dick for second
and cruz is in with a double all right
there you go couple of balls on the
barrel off the bat of nelson cruz
and he's aboard the lead off this edge
and karel off lashes one fair into the
left field corner that'll scroll through
and pure law
to second with an rbi double and it's
6-2
we'll face michael franco the
right-hander delivers and franco
crutches it left field on a line this
one is headed out of here
michael franco
a rocket on the express train out of the
ballpark and the orioles making a
five-run advantage as they get the run
back that they lost in the top half of
the inning seven two o's
driven to center field down for a hit
carol off will get one in
and he'll get two in with a two out
single
sedillo one for three began the night
and right now catching
and the 1-0 pitch a drive to left field
deep in the corner back it goes and go
on a home run for ostadio
and the twins are now down three
ostedio's fourth home run second hit
tonight it's a 7-4 baltimore league row
goes to first gets away towards the
camera well getting up is simmons mount
castle now they got him hung up he
throws in his second simmons being
chased back they flip to valdez down
goes the runner simmons is gone the
orioles catch a break
[Applause]
and it's grooved right down the middle a
base head that'll go to the wall crews
rounding second going to third he'll be
stopped there
and larnick jumped all over one that was
center cut and now the twins will bring
carol off to the plate as the tying run
2-2 on the way
popped him up
mullins is there and the orioles have
done it those nasty streaks have ended
the birds win for the first time since
may 16.
they snapped their 14-game losing streak
and they also snap a streak that has
seen them lose 16 straight to the twins
life is good again